[Aplausos]
[Música]
eres único diferente a todos los demás
pero hay una cosa que nos hace a todos
iguales nuestra capacidad de sentir
según el departamento de psicología de
la universidad de california el ser
humano es capaz de sentir 27 emociones
no les parece increíble que seamos capaz
de sentir las mismas emociones de forma
automática las mismas 27
cuando uno por ejemplo se ve una araña
no tiene que pensar en que sentir
reaccionó instintivamente es cierto y
eso es normal pero más allá que el hecho
de que seamos capaces de sentir y de que
podemos contar con ese sistema
maravilloso que nos mantiene vivos hay
algo que me llama aún más la atención el
hecho que solamente los sentimientos y
emociones considerados positivos sean
socialmente aceptados sobre todo en esa
era de redes sociales se sabe es el
lugar mágico en donde todos somos
perfectos felices buenos y generosos
el ser positivo está tan pero tan
ridículamente de moda que si saliendo de
acá me atropelló en camión se supone que
tengo que sentirme bien al respecto y
grato por la experiencia claro
sé feliz ama perdona esos mensajes los
escuchamos todos los días no pero qué
pasa con el odio con el miedo con la
envidia con la tristeza qué pasa con
todos esos otros sentimientos que
consideramos negativos a estos nos
reprimimos y lo venimos haciendo desde
hace mucho tiempo eso no es algo nuevo
allá en grecia los filósofos ya enseñaba
a la gente a evitar esos sentimientos
por siglos los libros sagrados de
diferentes religiones los han asociado
al mismo mal y para que se den cuenta de
cómo seguimos reprimiendo los con mucho
éxito hasta el día de hoy haremos un
rápido ejercicio ya de hecho es un
experimento les voy a pedir que en sus
cabezas piensen en el sentimiento que
mejor representa el bien
listos ahora les voy a pedir que piensen
en el sentimiento opuesto ese que mejor
representa el mal
amor y odio creo que más que sea divino
la mayoría de nosotros estamos de
acuerdo en eso porque hemos sido
enseñados a estar de acuerdo todo
comienza cuando eres niña y tienes que
aprender y nos enseñan a categorizar
cosas y categorizamos por colores por
formas por tamaños aprendemos miles de
hashtags mentales para ir separando y
almacenando toda esa información y
separar las cosas entre buenas y malas
es una de las primeras formas de
categorización que aprendemos porque es
fundamental para mantenernos vivos y eso
es muy muy importante no hay nada de mal
con eso el problema es que hay cosas que
no deberían estar categorizadas de esa
forma por ejemplo nuestras emociones
porque todos los días realizamos
acciones buenas y malas pero realizamos
motivados por cualquier tipo de
sentimiento o emoción eso es normal no
hay un tipo específico de emoción que
genere un tipo específico de acción
entonces qué pasa cuando rompemos ese
paradigma cuando dejamos de separar
sentimientos y emociones entre buenos y
malos entre los que debemos o no debemos
sentir
qué pasa cuando dejamos de reprimir esos
sentimientos que hoy consideramos
negativos
nos encontramos con una poderosa fuente
de energía emocional que nos puede
ayudar a lograr cosas que jamás pensamos
ser capaces
por ejemplo la historia de un chico que
su gran sueño había sido ser jugador de
baloncesto entonces a los 15 años él se
postula para participar en el equipo de
su colegio pero es rechazado por el
entrenador que lo considera malo de
hecho lo considera tan malo que siquiera
lo tiene en cuenta como suplente queda
totalmente afuera del equipo
el motivado por esos sentimientos en vez
de desistir usa ese odio ese rechazo a
esa frustración para entrenar y entrena
todos los días entrena duro reconoce sus
debilidades las mejoras mejora su juego
algunos años después ese chico llamado
michael jordan creo que lo conocen
llegaría a ser reconocido como uno de
los mayores atletas de todos los tiempos
pero eso no es un caso aislado
historias como esas hay muchos yo he
escuchado uno hace unos días que me ha
gustado mucho un chico me contaba la
historia de su papá quiere el único de
tres hermanos que no se había convertido
en abogado
era considerado como que el flujo de la
familia
se entiende no hay un junte familiar uno
de los hermanos se emborrachó y le dijo
tú no eres nadie tú no has hecho nada
con tu vida no eres exitoso no has
estudiado una carrera
eso lo dio él le dolió tanto le llegó
tan profundo que a los 50 años ha
comenzado a estudiar derecho y hoy es
una exitosa abogada
un minuto de humillación de dolor de
odio le ha servido más que 50 años de
apoyo familiar
ustedes creen que ellos y muchas otras
personas hubieran logrado todo lo que
lograron si hubieran reprimido sus
sentimientos en vez de usarlos a su
favor
pero la pregunta realmente importante
que quiero que todos se hagan hoy es
donde hubiera llegado tú si no hubieras
reprimido estos sentimientos toda tu
vida
lo bueno es que aún están a tiempo de
descubrir nunca es muy tarde y les voy a
compartir la forma como yo lo he hecho
como yo he descubierto el poder de esos
sentimientos lo primero que tienes que
hacer es buscar en tus recuerdos una
experiencia que te haya marcado de una
forma negativa pero tiene que ser
poderosa lo suficiente que el simple
hecho de recordarla reviva esa emoción
ese sentimiento de odio de injusticia de
envidia de rechazo yo sé que es doloroso
pero el poder de ese recuerdo te permite
revivir un sentimiento y por eso ese
será tu detonador y ahora viene la parte
divertida cada vez que sientas que no
eres capaz de hacer algo usa tu
detonador busca ese recuerdo esa vez que
tu ex novia te puso los cuernos
lo puedes usar
cuando alguien te diga que no vas a
lograr eso que te propones recuerdas esa
paliza que tenían en el colegio
cuando fracase es normal y tengas que
recomenzar una y otra vez recuerda el
día que tu padre te abandono
cada vez que usa estudia donador te
llenará de energía emocional y
descubrirás el verdadero poder de sus
sentimientos que has estado reprimiendo
toda tu vida todo por culpa de un
paradigma acerca de los sentimientos que
se supone que debemos no sentir todo por
culpa de un paradigma y espero que todo
mi corazón que se ha determinado hoy
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]